zwar versuchte aber er malte wovon er
träumt
welch ein rummel um ein bit schritt für
schritt inszeniert die von der song
thriller das auspacken eines gramm
bildes für die medien
bis es hängt der mythos um den malaga
wird bis heute zelebriert wie kaum ein
anderer
er hätte seine freude daran gehabt denn
schon zu lebzeiten inszenierte sich
polga als großer maler der in der ferne
sein glück suchte und zuhause verkannt
blieb kunstgeschichte und das ist
natürlich vor bis heute im ganzen
fasziniert und leben ist das thema es
waren letztlich nach vorne nach freiheit
nach glück in eine paradiesische kontext
das ist ein wunsch sehnsuchtsvoll süd
karl kein ende des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts gibt der börsenhändler
bolger seine bürgerliche existenz auf um
als künstler ein freies leben zu leben
bald ist in die pariser die kartons zu
viel und er macht sich auf ein
ursprüngliches leben zu suchen weg von
der westlichen zivilisation der
schauspieler udo kier einen bekennender
fan beschreibt die ernüchterung die
gugga erfasste als er im
kolonialisierten tahiti ankommt das war
ja europa jenes europa von dem ich
loszukommen
dazu unter den erschweren aspekten des
kolonialismus einer kindlichen und bis
zur karikatur grotesken nachahmung nicht
um das anzutreffen war ich so weit
gereist
yoga findet sein paradies nicht doch
eher beginnt das zu malen was er dafür
hält er installiert sich in einer hütte
weit weg von allem nimmt sich eine junge
maori zur frau und malt das unbefleckte
paradies seiner vorstellung
er malt nicht die polynesische realität
sondern bedient das klischeebild
seinerzeit bereits als paradies auf
erden beschrieben worte wo man aber
nicht schaffen muss
das sind sozusagen an den bäumen hängt
sicher gilt dass expedias packt das sind
alles themen wonach schon vor kunde hat
und wo nannte mittag geschafft hätten
als er das erste mal in paris des
fantasy etwa zurückkehrt fasziniert eher
als abenteurer und exot
doch seine bilder bleiben und verstanden
um sein image als will der maler
aufrecht zu erhalten
nimmt er sich als mose eine japanische
tänzerin und versucht seine bilder an
den mann zu bringen
dann sind hätte sicher gemacht und in
paris praktisch am image vom exoten
sprache sowie dozent sprache und da
hätte euch kauft in paris die bilder von
haiti qualität sozusagen durch präsenz
in hinter hauptstadt des cockpits
platzieren tomaten
google sah sich mit seinen exotischen
zuschuss als erneuerer der malerei der
egozentrische narzistische
persönlichkeit im mittelpunkt und
transsexuelle immer völlig überspannt
die erwartungen an sich und weltweit und
das letzte ticket können vier enttäuscht
von seinem misserfolg verlässt er
frankreich für immer er zieht sich auf
eine noch entlegenere südsee insel
zurück dort malt er sein heute
wichtigstes bild es ist ein lebenszyklus
von der geburt bis zum tod
eine art testament noch während er es
malt kündigt er an sich danach
umzubringen
ein weiterer schritt zur legendenbildung
um yoga auf denen insgesamt sehr schöne
schlacht einer schlacht gesundheit sie
gerade den tee traum vom tod seiner
tochter erfahren in denen und das ist
extremst schicksalsschlag sie zusammen
passt dass die verzweiflung ist nicht
einfach nur inszeniert sondern greift
realität
der suizid schlägt fehl zwischen
selbstüberschätzung und fehlende
anerkennung zwischen südsee romantik und
flucht aus europa liegt sogar mit seinem
leben die grundlage für eine der größten
mythen der kunstgeschichte